hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
freddy's i think we have a choice coming
up i think this game is going to make us
choose whether or not to rip the
eyeballs the ear balls and the balls out
of the other animatronics and fit them
into freddy here and then upgrade him
into super freddy i don't know how
that's going to change the game but that
seems to be the
idea from the previous one given that i
can still use the machine here and
there's other things here
select your desired procedure now
whatever i'm going to hop in
freddy i'm not exactly sure where i'm
supposed to go but there is a door over
here that says freddy's so maybe
i'm ready
oh
fascinating okay
so where would these go
i'm kind of curious actually
because if there is a place here
i doubt i can use that
it probably won't let me right
huh that's a weird button that button
don't look so good
hi freddy
wait did that just open
there's no way
no no no no what's my objective i don't
even know
use service elevators up to rockstar row
i would assume that these are service
elevators but it probably only opens for
freddy here so i'm gonna go ahead and
try that
can i
is this not the right place am i not on
the right spot yeah one second
you know these elevators i would have
thought that they were service elevators
but apparently not
well vanessa went down this one
so maybe this is the one i go now
oh
it's this one
okay
great
good
i've ready
just the two of us in here
remember how you killed me
that was another universe but do you
remember how i killed you you killed me
that was fun
anyway
[Music]
okay all right let me hop back in
and i'll be on my way i guess i should
have been evident because vanessa went
down this one but whatever
i'm sorry
who's crying
get back out there
get out of my room why were you crying
why were you crying
you okay there why i didn't know robots
could cry
strange
uh
vanessa are you out there too
oh you are out there
okay interesting
oh hey they got foxy stuff
i didn't even know foxy was still
acknowledged
okay but i remember i need to go to
chica's one
because that's
it's fine
remember how you left me left me
disassembled uh and for dead
level five but i just came out of there
how did i get out
ah vanessa
hey
how you doing
[Applause]
if i didn't i could collect that but i
don't exactly have time hi
hello
how you doing
you good
i don't have time for this okay all
right goodbye now well i'm almost there
i think i got level four
if i'm not mistaken
nope i'm wrong level five okay
so how am i supposed to get back
there i'm not hungry
you hungry
okay so i need to get into chica's room
i have a screwdriver
i can open up the vent
that means that i can go back to
freddie's room
go
in there hop out get in the vent
and then unscrew the vent where i need
to be i just better be sure i don't
unscrew montes
because i feel like that would be a
problem
okay i'm here now you just stand right
there i got it from here big guy
you stay safe now
i love you
come on out
oh i see there's just no time to say it
back i get it whatever i don't need to
press that button oh okay
sure
fine
i'll go here then
and not save
suspicious but okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay
silly stuff silly stuff that thing
better not be in these vents
i'm gonna be a bit of a pain in the ass
huh
all right but i was already in there
so i don't need to go in there again
and then there was
yo sure yeah you can vanessa actually
you know what i'd be willing to bet that
you can
and that you actually have nothing to do
with them
oh my god
um
like to reiterate the fact that i have
not saved
in a spell
ah
so
you know
yep that's what i thought okay well i'll
be back guys
hold on hello
it's freddy get out of my room hey
foxy what were you crying about who are
you being a big uh bubble-blowing baby
about
what were you uh sobbing and heaving
what was that all about huh
what do you uh have to say for yourself
nothing okay man i gotta get this thing
you know oh don't look in this doorway
why
why why
i just had to get this four block shirt
it's not that big a deal
don't worry about it so much
okay whatever you have fun doing
whatever you were doing crying
low power oh well that wasn't a problem
before i don't know why it's suddenly a
problem now
all right all right i get it i hear
all right oh now i can save
something was just
broken before
all right whatever
totally fine
uh
you didn't oh yes you did all right no
that's not what i wanted to do i wanted
to step aside so i could pop out
okay
so let me save
apparently i can do that now
which is good
yes
okay now let me
blast this flashlight up
and this time i'm just gonna realize
that i probably have to run from the get
go because that thing is obviously gonna
be there and i just gotta go to chica's
thing
as much as i would like to enter
monty's room which i really would i
don't know why but i really would
i would really like that
i'm gonna try it i probably don't have
enough time to try it but i want to try
it
this is what i want to do
can you fault me for that
oh yeah you can fault me for that
because i don't have time
and it probably wouldn't work anyway
okay okay enough of that enough of that
enough of that
enough
there we go
yep yep yep i'm in
oh
hey pal
okay
i'm gonna ignore the fact that that
didn't exist
it's fine
that didn't exactly uh open
or whatever i think i'm getting the pass
now
you should be able to see their
locations on the map what
oh oh
um bad children must be found yeah oh
hey okay you're swimming
all right hold on recharge station is
said but there's a recharge station in
your room right where you is hi
restart station do i go in why do i go
in
why am i in here
i'm in you now gregory if that party
pass is very special it will let you
into phaserblast or montegolf however it
can only be used once great
how do i use it just give it to a party
bot they usually stay in front of the
attractions collecting party passes if
you have one it will let you in i have
marked both locations on your map
have you
you did what
no you didn't
no you did not
you didn't do that don't lie to me
freddy you didn't mark [ __ ] on my map
what are you talking about big guy
all right whatever
zap him up to chargey because apparently
his charge really drains
all right whatever i don't know if that
moon man is still going to be there but
it's 4 a.m now and that means it's time
to go play some phaser blast look i love
mini golf just as much as the next guy
but i can't if this is going to be a
physics-based golf game
i'm going to go with
i'm going to go with the laser blast
because at least i know i can point and
shoot
all right
uh let's go i guess okay away
and away
[Applause]
oh wait i forgot this door doesn't quite
open
but i know a back way
isn't there a button that i can like
summon freddy isn't that a thing that
he'll come get me
or find me at least
like if i
hang him
oh [ __ ]
oh he common i better be freddie
please tell me that's freddy
okay okay okay okay okay okay uh uh
buddy i'm over here
oh hi okay yeah thanks pal
all right i always feel safe when you're
around
all right let's go why can't you move
that fast when i'm uh hiding inside you
why uh why is that so slow
all right we're looking for phaser blast
i don't know where phaser blast is it
was conveniently marked on my mini map
oh wait faster blast
okay
cool first floor or second floor
first floor first of all yes
yes definitely 100 100
anyone that picks monty golf is just a
nerd
it's a goddamn nerd
what a nerd move to make
coming give me something to shoot
hello
oh you yeah i need to talk to you
um ignore what you're about to see
because it'll probably be very
disturbing for your robot brain
it's me a human
hi
take this
oh
yeah
where did you go
come with me
come to me friend
we need to go i guess
no no no time for that
can't use too much power now can we
[Music]
and we're here
um
no hold on i don't know if i need you
just yet
uh
come on through
man you are adorable but also terrifying
so i don't know how much i appreciate
you all right
cool so how do i get
a gun
eh
oh
okay
all right
i don't think i'm supposed to be in this
restroom given that i'm not a chicken
i'm willing to bet that there's some
kind of uh secret in here that's the
only reason i want to explore this
oh space chica keychain okay well that's
pretty cool i guess
all right i'm gonna go blast some things
now
oh
well hold on before i blast some things
perfect
how many collectibles are there in this
game
and do they do anything space wrong see
keychain well that's nice
that's very nice
that's real nice all right well let me
save so i don't have to get those again
okay the game is a foot
you must be the new freezer blast
recruits and from the looks of you the
orange blue team hasn't got a chance
soon you will be fighting for your lives
on a hostile alien planet but first i am
here to tell you how to play freezer
blast
there are two rules you must follow at
all times rule number one no running no
climbing no jumping no hitting kicking
pushing shoving no shooting as blasters
in near or close to other players eyes
being flashed in the eyes may induce
seizures blindness or semi-permanent
paralysis if you are flashed in the eyes
immediately flush your eyes with soap
and water then blink repeatedly until
vision is restored
rule number two have fun
do you want to hear the rules again
no no no no warning phaser blast is a
high energy space combat simulation
people with medical conditions are
allowed to participate my medical
software makes me a qualified doctor and
i approve of this message
by listening to these instructions you
have waived all rights and ability to
make any claims against fazbear
entertainment any accidents or injuries
are your sole responsibility or a shared
responsibility between you and any
associated party involved in said
incident
now get in there and fight fight fight
okay sounds good hey i'm in space this
reminds me of my upcoming youtube
original in space with markiplier the
teaser trailer of which you can see
those on my channel
all right am i not going to be able to
shoot anything because i seem to not
have a gun
i thought that i was going to get a
laser blaster you know or you can enter
the arena you need to grab the helmet
and has blaster
who's talking
can i grab a helmet and faz blaster
fast blaster with the phaser blast
equipped
press
to zap bots in the eyes and stun them
oh hell yeah
switch one into ah okay
i see
oh
why is my vision all wonky
why'd my vision go wonk
why is my vision all wonk
uh whatever
probably fine
okay
so uh
i go in now
i go in you are on the orange team
soldier report to the orange hallway
okay i'm on the orange team i didn't
know i picked
hello
oh
okay
look at that oh why is that happening
oh here we go i guess
this one's first oh god
okay
great
this
i'm out of shot
hang on hold on hold on hold on
i hope i'm recharging my blaster too
i might do i that's a flashlight blaster
that's a flash blaster this is not one
or the other it's both at the moment
try me try me try me try me try me you
want to go you want to go
you want to go
where are you where did you go
that's what you get where did the flag
go i found it once i'll never find it
again ah i found
it i have captured the flag does that
mean i take it back to my base
oh i just have to reload
black flag lost
but i had it
time to defend
oh time to defend
i see what you're talking about
i see i see what's going on here wow
stop
try me
doesn't seem to reload as much as it
just uh
seemed to be out of bazookas try
i
did it
i win
you have defeated the alien army good
job space cadet proceed to the winner's
elevator for your reward
okay
what do i get
and which one's the whoa fredbear's
singing show
ah
okay whatever the hell that is
all right so i gotta go get my reward
where's my reward where's the winners
elevator there should probably be a sign
that says winners
or something like that
i see exit
is that for the dejected losers or is
that for winners
that's for dejected losers
where's the winners exit where do i go
this
no
not even close
uh
i'm a winner
i'm a winner i wanna win her
no
okay
um
all right then
winner no
win no
winner i'm gonna spare you the
excessively long time that i spend
looking for the exit and instead show
you this box
this is the return box where i was
supposed to put my gun before it would
allow me into the elevator
i spent way too long looking for this
and we don't have time for me to show
you all of it so instead here's a mashup
of me losing my mind
enjoy win win i won i won i want to win
now i want to get the win the wind that
i won i'm so blinded by my success that
i can't possibly discover where the
winter elevator would be the winner what
is the winner elevator what do you mean
what do you mean help
help i'm lost i won which means i get to
play laser blaster forever sorry phaser
blast for the rest of my days until
someone takes my crown from me i am
damned to play this game forever and a
day and if i ever don't people will hunt
me down and kill me i mean animatronics
will hunt me down and kill me i'm not
making a reference to anything else
this is purely about phasor blast wait
wait
oh
oh i had to return my
well done superstar you won the faster
blaster
now go collect your price from the
superstar lounge
i had to put my phaser blaster in the
faster blaster return did it tell me to
return
the faster blaster did it tell me that
i uh
i don't remember if that's what i was
told
i wish i had played mini gold i really
do
i would have uh
probably
had a
more fulfilling experience okay i win
what do i win this golden fashion class
clam yeah that's what i'm talking about
oh
yeah where does this vent go why would i
not go back to freddy can i not i can go
i'm going in the vent
going in the vent has never not worked
out for me
so i will go in the vent
where does this thing go
oh
oh oh no it's fine
okay
well
this is interesting why am i here
this something i get to choose to do or
is this
just there new hire summary head
security guard no prior qualifications
internal reference name withheld
she's a personality chip has always been
a bit quirky but the new pizza flavored
monty mystery mixed slushie syrup has
adverse effects on her programming she
has attacked patrons employees and staff
for it it is recommended that monty
mystery mix should be recalled before we
are inundated with lawsuits
again
do you mean again
maybe you shouldn't give these
animatronics so much free will and maybe
you shouldn't put personality chips in
them maybe you shouldn't allow them to
eat anything at all maybe you shouldn't
build animatronics that have a desire to
eat maybe you shouldn't build
animatronics have any desires whatsoever
blast
it looks like a hideout
i think her name is
fanny
it is very similar to vanessa
and also
bunny
that cannot be a coincidence it could be
a coincidence don't you go assuming
anything
let's be clear now
you don't know what you're talking about
okay well i saw that but why did i saw
that and how does that affect me
oh here's the stairs that i was looking
at before can i have nope
so what was the point of coming over
here
was there a point of coming over did i
miss something is there something that i
missed
i'd like to think that there's not
something that i missed so i'm gonna go
back assuming that there's nothing that
i missed maybe this was just an easter
egg that i saw and could have easily
missed and not gone
i'm glad i went there
don't know why that other walkway was
there though but whatever i'm glad i
went
okay hi fred freddy oh not here yet
okay
freddy
[Applause]
freddy man
freddie man
good job superstar you got the faster
blaster
but you had to use your party pass if
you find the security office i am sure
you will find something that will help
you
just watching him charge after me was
delight
it's just like freddy charging at you in
a circumstance where death is not
imminent is not a not a usual sensation
for me
all right well done guys let's uh
celebrate and be happy good job all
around i now have a phaser blaster
that's going to help me deter those
pesky animatronics from trying to eat my
brains
and on my bones
both things that i prefer not to occur i
have a phaser blaster
ever heard of it nerd no you guys who
played golf would have no idea come on
boy come on come on boy come on i got a
fancy treat
i lied i don't have one
oh don't be surly
[Music]
hurry come over
all right we're here
don't worry freddy
i'll defend you
now where the hell are we going
i don't remember there being much of an
objective oh
find out how to decommission monty find
out how to decommission chica
ah
well i don't have a party pass anymore
so i can't exactly do that
investigate the phaser blast office well
yeah i want to do that but how
how do i do that
i don't know all right so we gotta
figure out a way to decommission chica
sad to say but chica's gotta go
oh who's this
hello
hi
where the hell am i
come on boy there you are
uh
okay oh these are all the different um
restaurants that were in the food
gallery
i guess now i'm just kind of free to
explore
oh that's nice like whatever i do is
just what i do i guess
where does this go
where does that go okay
hi you gonna bother me don't bother me
don't you dare bother me i ain't
bothering you you don't bother me
uh week it was jenkins forgetting to
replace the urinal cakes after a single
use yesterday was elsa for showing up
too early today it's me because lily h
asked for chicken alfredo i said we
don't make that here her father guy
looked like sasquatch by the way
demanded to speak to a manager i get
dennis dennis asked me why i don't just
get her what she wants i say we don't
have chicken alfredo dennis fires me on
the spot joke's on him though turns out
our new staff bots the better employees
aren't programmed to make chicken
alfredo so hq fired him for firing me
sweet revenge thanks lily
okay man that was a interesting read
come on boy
where are we
why are we here
can i have some chicken alfredo ah
i guess right now i'm just finding
collectibles
a pinata
a weird looking pinata
can i talk to you for a second
all right roxy is that you
roxy
roxy come here i got something to show
you
open your
eyes i bet i'm here
bam oh bam
all right so what do i do
y'all right there you okay
oh
no
well i didn't miss you either what
happens no i can't do anything okay
well that was interesting
bam
hi freddy um hold on hold your horses
hold your horse your horse needs to be
held you can't hide forever i'm not
trying to hide forever i'm trying to
shoot you
okay whatever that's handy but whatever
not what i need
hi
where the hell am i
where am i
how is there so much to this place
get blasted
i said
okay apparently not
this thing's useless
oh oh my god oh my god
oh my god
that might be the creepiest thing i've
ever seen
oh my oh my god okay that's
fine the hell is this
the hell is this supposed to be
why are you here
come on boy
wow
spooky cheek is feeding frenzy oh
okay
good
why is the monty golf arcade in the mini
golf course it makes absolutely no sense
it seems to work okay otherwise
i don't know why is it
okay hey what's up
all right whatever it's fine
well no one seems to have come so your
security doing is not exactly very
helpful
hi
level five okay chica feeding frenzy in
the bakery won't turn off even when
unplugged the game just keeps running
there's no way it has that much residual
charge
yeah well things don't seem to work
properly around here no matter what you
do um
investigate the phasor blast office
wait hold on was i not done in faster
blast
was i supposed to go to the faster blast
office is that different than the office
that i saw do i need to find another way
into that office
wait was i not done there
wait
what
how was i not done
oh oh my god hi i thought you were
freddy
no
that's a bad wolf
that's a bad bubble i heard that heard
what you losing
uh okay office office office office
there's gotta be an office around here
somewhere somewhere there's an office
there's something up there i guess it
was kind of a thing where it was just
like oh there's something here to
actually investigate maybe i should go
find it or
something i didn't know that i actually
needed to follow up though
do i need to go back up there
is that what i need
uh
fine i will go back there
oh cool
hello
interesting
oh
hello
hey that's
weird
okay you okay buddy
you all right come on freddy come on
oh oh oh my god oh my god hi freddy
hey how you doing okay i guess i need to
go back up there must have been another
office that i could have entered before
freddy
freddy come on
freddie you can do it come on
freddie
ready
freddy
you there
i miss our private moments in the
elevator
oh you're not here
what
okay whatever he's gone apparently
so
here
no
[Music]
oh i was supposed to go here the whole
time i was supposed to go i was out in
the world doing god knows what
please take all monty mystery mix to the
frozen ice cream storage behind the
bowling alley additional instructions
will follow
there's a bowling alley cool anyway they
know i'm here ah whatever it's okay
i'm fine i haven't saved in a while
i should have saved
look you got an annual bonnie bowl
unlimited pass free bowling for a whole
year mega pizza plex entry not included
shoe and ball rental fees still apply
thanks freddie thank you for that i
thought i was in some kind of a hurry
but apparently not
tie up your hair
okay sure
no i don't want to recharge my
flashlight i want this
thanks
oh i got level five
oh yes i know what security badges do
thank you very much
okay
so i have level five now
that's very good i
you said something about them knowing
i'm here
what did you mean by that
well okay well this isn't exactly a
problem because i can just hop in you
and go on my merry way
think
and let me look at my mission
okay that's it all right okay
let me uh just squeeze out a save here
and then i'll be on my way
i guess i'm gunning it
freddy come on
ready ready ready ready
fred freddy freddy
fred freddy
freddy
uh i think he jumped down
already freddie where are you
are you in the room right now freddy
okay i made it
well now what i have level five but i
still don't exactly know what to do with
it
i could go into uh
either their rooms now
monty or chica i could do that
that's something to do
hi
how did i get there before i don't even
remember
this place is a maze and then once we're
there
we pop over here i go right into
grabbing this
and then i go right into
hello
someone here
what is that
what's that
what is
i don't know what's happening
something's broken there
anyway can i go in here now
i can oh
oh
well
now that i'm here i don't exactly know
what i was intending to do
monty mischief monty didn't show up for
the main stage performance again we
found him in the same place we always do
the cat walks over monty golf we can't
have a repeat of last month someone hit
the hole in one and the hurricane bucket
knocked him down both legs were broken
and required emergency parts
we paid for the glam freddy mega deluxe
party package and freddie broke down as
soon as he got on stage we paid to have
him at the table and sing happy birthday
he was supposed to give her the cake my
daughter's birthday has been ruined i
demand a refund
it is fazbear entertainment's company
policy to not issue refunds in the
situation where freddie freaks the [ __ ]
out it's not our fault and go away
no that's golden
that's weird
oh
cue the big giant thumbnail with golden
freddy in the title being golden freddy
insecurity bees
like a lot of fireworks going off right
now the theorists are just eating it all
up
okay well i didn't get any closer to
figuring out how to stop
monty
i haven't really seen anything monty
this whole game let me go try chica
maybe chica's got some
something else i don't know
some kind of clue
oh apparently i've already been in here
that's right
this is where i first went in
i don't need to come here
well then where am i supposed to go i'm
thinking that it's got to be something
to do with the food right
it's got to be something to do with that
right
it's got to be some
the trash compactor
right
if i could get
chica in the trash compactor
then i would be able to
decommission chica
there's something up there
i'm in the wrong place
i am in the wrong space
but that's okay
oh
creepy
all
right i'll be right back i'm gonna get
back to where i was
trying to get to uh
that kitchen area and i know the way
that i went before so i'm just gonna try
to get that
got something else what do we have
with bonnie out of commission we are
making monty the new bass player bonnie
why is bonnie out of commission parts
and service has already done the proper
adjustments this could be a good thing
monty could he be even more popular than
bonnie
somehow i doubt that
but
wishful thinking i guess
there's gotta be something else here oh
flashlight battery upgrade oh good
i didn't even know that was possible to
find stuff like that
what other upgrades are there
what the hell well let me save before i
do that and also i'm not going to go
this way because i know it just goes
back to where i was before i just got to
get to the front area i'm just being
stupid about how i'm getting there
and i refuse to be stupid oh
hey
hi
hey guys
how you doing good to see you here man
that's
interesting
okay now i'm back here so i know how to
get back to the
the chicken the kitchen the kitchen
chicken the chicken's kitchen area
i mean no one will miss you either but
you know whatever
so i gotta go over there to that
that vent by salads and sides
and if i go in the vent in salads and
sides
i can slide my way down to the area it's
a bit circuitous but i don't quite
remember the other connector to that so
i just gotta trust my gut on this one
i'm gonna go to salads and sides
and then i'm gonna get lost
in there but eventually i'll get spat
out to the trash compactor and i bet if
i put chica right in that trash
compactor everything's going to be
hunky-dory
i wonder if i can shoot this mini music
man in the eyes with my laser blaster
don't even think about it what just
happened what is happening what's
happening what's happening what's
happening what was that
okay i knew you were coming
that was you
okay what happens if i do one of these
there's nothing
and we're slide and yay here we are this
actually might be the only way to get
here because i uh no there was weight
out so there must be a way in
i don't know but i don't remember it at
least i got to experience that all again
thank you now i'm going
okay i already got that
what are you guys doing here
freddy oh
freddy can't find me
looks like i'm on my own
interesting
okay well that wasn't so bad
not so bad not so bad and the kitchen is
right down there there's security blocks
patrolling it so i'm assuming that's a
good sign
because that means they expected me to
be here which is why they updated the
things that are in here
they said oh the laundry
right good thing i didn't have to go
through the laundry again i would have
lost my mind
i only had a
what oh
okay
did my brain
uh not work for a moment there or was
there
just a black nothingness that i was
staring into
okay
this is fine i'll take this
this is all good all staff meeting to
all staff meeting this thursday is 11 30
pm all service team attendance is
mandatory there will be cake
that's quite a late meeting
what you doing that late
and whatever fun
okay so in here
so first and foremost
there must be some way that i lead
i lead chica in here probably i make
another pizza or something like that you
know what i mean
but also the wire the wire i remember
following the wire the wire the wire yes
okay so the wire was over here
the wire's going up there
which means that i'm going up there
oh hi chica uh
nope no freddy okay
that's fine i have my laser blaster
if you try anything i'm gonna blast you
so good right in your eyeballs
look for this
what does this do
i turned that was a mission i guess
wham
block block
yeah yeah okay so i turned that on
so i primed it what i should do is get
chica over here shoot her in the
eyeballs when she's in the
hey send an alert out
i'm in a bad bad boy whoa too close too
close all right get in here get in here
get in here get in here chica come here
chica come here
chica
chica hey hey
hey numbnuts
hello this way this way come along now
come along now
right here come on look close don't be
shy come on
i'm right here in front of your face
look with your eyes not with your thighs
hello
gregory yeah uh-huh i'm right here
hi what's up how you doing you don't
want to go in the trash compactor you
afraid of it
you afraid you scared you scared you
scared a little baby scary little baby
done one go in the dress competitor
scare little baby number one go in the
grass maker hmm that's too bad
you got oh my god there you are okay
so that's interesting
i need something to lure chica into the
trash compactor fine ah
oh
find monty mystery mix in bonnie bowl
okay
how do i get to bonnie it better be real
easy it better be real easy
my friendly security staff can help it
better be really easy
it better be mega easy
oh that's right i got an all-exclusive
lifetime pass to bonnie bowl
ah
i understand now i get it i get it i get
it i see where it all connects i got all
of them
hi okay thank you for that where is whoa
whoa hey
also what the hell happened here
yeah staff only what the hell happened
here
this is a wreck in here
something went down
ah no
yep
sorry yeah no this is this is a mess
uh-huh
you know what i'm looking for a way out
of this place
how do i get out of here how do i get to
bonnie bowl i want to go to bonnie bowl
i'm gonna go bowling with bonnie i don't
like monty i want bonnie i'm seeing this
oh god give it give it give it give give
give kick
golden cheek whoa
what the lore the lord guys the lore the
lord
ring the lore alarms the lord
the lord
guys the lord
we got a new piece of the puzzle
golden chica who'd have thought it was
even possible i always suspected i
always knew there was another component
to this
oh yes i secretly suspected it all along
but i didn't say it out loud because i
was wondering when confirmation was
going to come my way
and now it has
and now i know
the lore
the lore is finally complete
it's the one puzzle piece missing that
was just
oh so gently removed from everything
else
and now it's here
what does it mean
isn't it obvious
i won't spoil the surprise i'll let you
figure it out on your own but it all
makes sense now
it all makes sense
i have no idea where i'm going i'm
literally just stalling for time
where am i
oh
i'm in the atrium okay well that was
helpful i didn't know that elevator went
back there but now i do
okay good good good good i just need to
go to the bowling
a bonnie bowl
locked on
target
locked
on target
hey bonnie nice shirt
bonnie it's been a while
missed you
where you been
fazzcade well that does sound fun but
i'll get to that later i gotta go to the
all exclusive bonnie bowl
i got a free year pass hello excuse me i
have a pass
take this
yeah you're welcome you're welcome
you're welcome i know i know i know yeah
yeah i know i know i i okay get out
well last parting gift i guess
i'll try to get in there
i'd like to think that if this was a
little more high fidelity that was roxy
just running so fast in the elevator
doors it like looney tunes just like she
left an imprint of her whole face and
arms stuck into the elevator door like
wonk right is it closed god i wish that
happened actually that did happen that
that's that's what happened in my mind
and you can't tell me otherwise freddy
oh i can't even get freddy here oh
that's
concerning
but i'll have to get to that in the next
episode i am all out of time for now
thank you everybody so much for watching
i had a little bit of wandering in this
one but i eventually made my way to
where i was supposed to be and i'm
pretty sure i'm supposed to be right
here and then i'm going to throw chica
in the trash compactor because i'm
seditious like that so thank you
everybody so much for watching remember
i have a new collection of cloak
available at cloakbrand.com and me and
my buddies we do a podcast every monday
at distractable
podcast.com i think that website works
i'm not a hard percentage links are in
the description thank you
more five nights at freddy's coming soon
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you